and traffic anchor nate tannenbaum
hoping for one big takeaway from our
look at the city's most dangerous
intersections so he's wrapping up that
five-part series we've been showing you
this week with an intersection that you
might actually not even think of as an
intersection
every intersection on our most dangerous
list we're talking about charleston and
rainbow saharan decatur flamingo and
pecos flamingo boulder highway and
nellis they all would be safer if we all
took better care whether we're behind
the wheel or on foot
and what about off the surface streets
with the exceptions of no bus stops and
hopefully no pedestrians everything
we've talked about all week long is only
amplified when it comes to freeways
now technically where i-15 meets the 215
southern beltway is an intersection
freeway or surface street the director
of unlv's road equity project aaron
breen hears the frustration of southern
nevadans looking at themselves in
society's mirror anymore you know
people don't go to court
they
don't have it reported to their
insurance company what lesson is if
there's no consequence so we've got to
go back to having consequences for
people who drive badly it needs to be a
community effort and it's a quality of
life issue
if you think it's a quality of life
issue speak up to the people that you
elect and tell them it's important to
you
a little bit of a soapbox there now if
most of us are remembering to do better
and we can count on people who do worse
facing enforced consequences
maybe all intersections can become less
dangerous shout out to aaron breen for
the great conversation metro police for
the crash statistics and eight news now
photojournalist matt adams for the cruel
drone video all week back to you
by the way the drone video was really
cool well you get a better perspective
of what you're talking about when you
can see it from above right and some of
those intersections if you missed them
charleston and rainbow saharan decatur
flamingo and pecos when he talked about
this segment we're all kind of guessing
the intersections those can be pretty
hairy especially along boulder highway